richard good morning this is jd
danny mccabe uh first and foremost thank
you sir for even considering my story
the third gift my dance for the devil
and her mother
it is a book that i was highly
encouraged to write
by professionals uh by family and
friends because of the
nightmare situation that i went through
as my marriage collapsed my 23 year
marriage
so the book really i hope highlights an
opportunity
for your listeners your audience to see
an example of
an individual who has not only
reestablished his identity
as a man and as a father but who's also
looking to
take the traumatic experience and make
myself even better
i've created a little business around it
and i'm hoping to
do what i can to give back to others
through sale of the proceeds of the book
long story short the first two gifts are
my kids
the third gift is a revelation that my
now ex-wife made between
our attorneys that helped me to uncover
and unlock several boxes of deception
uh that that occurred in our marriage so
everything that she accused me of doing
which
began to unravel me as a man hollowed me
out emotionally
pushed me to the brink turns out
everything she accused me of doing she
actually was doing everything from
infidelity
to drug addiction she alienated me from
my daughter
um prior to us separating i spent nine
days in psychiatric lock-up i was
emotionally hollowed out um by her mom
and her and the biggest mistake that i
made
is i kept myself on an island and i have
a very large network and i told nobody
about it
and it down there cost me my life
so prior to us even separating i spent
nine days in a psychiatric facility
which i would later discover that she
played a hand
in having me involuntarily committed
and then once we separated and she
revealed the third gift to me which was
a i don't mind telling you it was an std
it was herpes
it opened my eyes as i said previously
to everything that she
had been accusing me of doing she
actually was doing so i discovered five
years of
addiction to amphetamines two of those
years she used our kids to fill
prescriptions in their names to the tune
of 600 days
and i also uncovered that she had a long
history of stds that were treated by
antibiotics so at the very high level
i'm hoping for the story to not only be
an example to others men and women
that there is an opportunity to grow
through adversity there's an opportunity
to
not take the victim mindset but rather
the survivor
mentality and in addition to
that i'm hoping to for providing a
little bit of encouragement
a little bit of hope and a little bit of
inspiration
so in addition to nine days in the
psychiatric facility and uncovering
all of the deception that my now ex-wife
hid for me
i would discover that she was also
poisoning me with arsenic
so i'm not only a survivor of being
married to a closet
narcissist somebody with borderline
personality disorder that she unleashed
her demons on me 17 years into the
marriage which i believe
is related back this daddy issue she had
in her childhood
which i lay out in the book so in the
book i
walk people through this entire journey
and hopefully show them resilience
strength
and the ability to come out the other
side so arsenic survivor nine days in
psychiatric lock-up
survived the broken health care system
the broken mental health care system and
also a long journey through the
very biased family law court system
um i've become somewhat familiar with
your platform and i really like what
you're doing
and if you have any further questions
regarding my story i'd be i'd be happy
to chat with you
um that is it in a synopsis it's a
it's an unbelievable journey of
rediscovering myself and not only
rediscovering myself but making myself
better
in the process and also having to
re-establish a relationship with my
daughter
because it alienated me from my my
daughter for two years
as well so thank you sir again for
considering my request
okay so i'll i'll pull that out of the
screen i think that
i think that kind of sets the tone for
what all happened to you
and what you're up against
you